Hyden do wish your smartphone tablet
charger computer would last longer they
are not cheap so why can't they be
repaired and all this packaging for food
in the supermarket isn't it time to do
something about it we all love fashion
and clothes but no one wants to harm the
planet yet the textile industry uses
large amounts of water and too many
resources well D U has decided to act we
are changing our economy so that our
products are and industries become smart
clean greener we are seven billion
people on the one single clan our needs
can grow but the planet can't but we can
change the economy the way we do
business consume and produce can be more
efficient it's the only way our
communities can live better together the
circular economy
it's our circular future the circle of
life